you could have natural Botox sitting in your kitchen right now
and not even know it
and I know this because I'm 37 years old
I've never done Botox filler
any type of cosmetic procedures
cause I don't wanna add more toxins to my body after the black mold exposure
and Botox is a neurotoxin
and this is one of the best natural Botox things you can do
it keeps my skin plump
tight hydrated
moisturize and it's doing banana peel scrubs
first step is you wanna eat your banana because they're packed with vitamin C
B6 and potassium
they're antifungal
help fight off viruses and support good gut health
so if you're not able to eat a banana
then store them in the freezer for your next smoothie
but you're definitely gonna use that banana peel
then take your banana peel and start rubbing it gently all over your face
you'll be hydrating your skin from the inside out from the potassium it contains
the vitamin B is anti aging
the vitamin E protects your skin's protective layer
and the tannins of the banana peels helps reduce redness
tighten pores and reduce inflammation
and let the banana peel residue sit on your face for 10 minutes
wash it off and you can do your regular skincare routine
it's super easy
something you can do everyday
and make sure to follow me for more skin tips